"House of the Dragon" is full of new faces,
and not all of them used to belong to "The Doctor."
Here's where else you've seen the talented
cast.
Someone must always sit on the Iron Throne,
and at the start of "House of the Dragon,"
that responsibility falls to King Viserys
Targaryen, played by veteran actor Paddy Considine.
King Viserys is described in HBO's official
promotions for the series as a "good man,"
setting him miles apart from the "Game of
Thrones" character who later bears his name.
Outside of Westeros, Considine has had a long
and varied career in both film and television.
A versatile and lauded performer, he's equally
well known for indie films like "Dead Man's
Shoes" and "In America" and big-budget blockbusters
like "The Bourne Ultimatum."
"I can't think.
I can't laugh.
I can't cry.
I can't feel!"
He's also collaborated with Simon Pegg and
Nick Frost on "Hot Fuzz" and "The World's End."
Considine's other major TV roles include Claude
Bolton in the Stephen King adaptation "The
Outsider," and the despicable Father John
Hughes in the British crime saga "Peaky Blinders."
Though the Targaryens are at the center of
"House of the Dragon," they're far from the
only great house in Westeros with a stake
in the game.
One of the other major players is House Hightower
— a family that doesn't play an especially
major role in "Game of Thrones," but which
has a long and storied history on the continent.
One of the main characters in "House of the
Dragon" is Alicent Hightower, daughter of
Ser Otto Hightower, the Hand of the King.
Teenage Alicent is played by newcomer Emily
Carey.
Alicent Hightower is brought to life as an
adult by English actor Olivia Cooke, a young
star who's nonetheless accrued a lot of notable
credits in her career.
"Ruben?
You hurt yourself?
You hurt me.
I'll hurt myself too.
I'll hurt myself too."
Cooke first rose to prominence starring in
a couple of BBC miniseries, including "The
Secret of Crickley Hall" — alongside "Game
of Thrones" star Maisie Williams.
She's also plied her trade in the Alfred Hitchcock-inspired
series "Bates Motel" and the ITV historical
drama "Vanity Fair."
On the big screen, Cooke has appeared in films
like "Sound of Metal" and Steven Spielberg's "Ready Player One."
What would "A Song of Ice and Fire" be without
a few cool, enigmatic rogue warrior types?
That's the archetype that Lord Corlys Velaryon
falls into in "House of the Dragon," though
you'd be wrong to write him off as simply
a trope.
Viewed in his day as the best sea captain
in all of Westeros, Corlys hails from a family
nearly as prestigious as House Targaryen.
A key part of the royal court and a respected
ruler in his own right, the Sea Snake isn't
a man to be trifled with.
"Four ships have now been lost!
The last one was flying my banner."
You might not immediately recognize the name
Steve Toussaint — but you've almost certainly
seen him in something.
The Hollywood veteran has had a long career,
with credits that range from genre fare like
"Prince of Persia: The Sands of Time" to serious
dramas on the stage and screen.
Toussaint is most prolific on television,
though, with roles in "The Knock," "Inspector
Lewis," and Netflix's "Pine Gap."
At the center of the drama in "House of the
Dragon" is Prince Daemon Targaryen, played
by British star Matt Smith.
The younger brother of King Viserys and uncle
to Princess Rhaenyra, Daemon is a dragonrider,
warrior, and all-around major player in the
politics of the continent.
A complicated figure to say the least, he
played a major role in the Dance of the Dragons
and the preceding political turmoil, in part
because of his own desire for power.
Most fans of sci-fi and fantasy television
will instantly recognize Smith as the Eleventh
Doctor in "Doctor Who," a role he played for
three seasons from 2010 to 2013 and for which
he gained widespread acclaim.
"How very skinny.
That is proper skinny.
I've never seen him from the outside."
Fans of historical dramas may know Smith better
for his role as Prince Philip in Netflix's
"The Crown" — a performance that earned
him a Primetime Emmy nomination in 2018.
On the big screen, Smith is known for roles
like Jack in Edgar Wright's "Last Night in
Soho," Alex in "Terminator Genisys," and the
villainous Milo in "Morbius."
The main action of "House of the Dragon" precedes
and involves the Dance of the Dragons, a civil
war of sorts fought between different Targaryen
claimants to the Iron Throne.
One of those claimants is Princess Rhaenyra
Targaryen, played as an adult by Emma D'Arcy .
An actor equally at home on the stage and
the screen, D'Arcy started out in various
live theater productions in the U.K. before
landing some TV and film roles.
D'Arcy appeared in the 2020 British comedy
"Misbehaviour," the BBC drama "Baptiste" and
the ITV comedy drama "Wild Bill," just to
name a few roles.
The role of Rhaenyra in "House of the Dragon"
is undoubtedly D'Arcy's highest-profile role
to date — one shared by Australian newcomer
Milly Alcock, who plays the Princess as a 15-year-old
Every "Game of Thrones" fan knows what an
important (and often dangerous) position the
Hand of the King is in Westeros.
Depending on the current monarch of the land,
the Hand may wind up being the true ruler
behind the scenes.
Like his father before him, King Viserys Targaryen
relies on Otto Hightower as his Hand, played
in "House of the Dragon" by Rhys Ifans.
A longstanding member of the royal court and
a man of nearly impeccable reputation, Otto
is also the father of Alicent Hightower — a
role that ends up pulling him even further
into the messy family politics of the Targaryens.
A Welsh actor and longtime star of the screen,
Ifans is probably best known for his roles
in "Notting Hill" …
"C'mon.
Open up.
This is me...
Spiky."
… the "Harry Potter" franchise, and as Dr.
Curt Connors (aka the Lizard) in "The Amazing Spider-Man."
Ifans has also had a number of prominent television
roles, including playing Sherlock Holmes'
older brother Mycroft in the CBS crime procedural
"Elementary."
Dragonrider, overlooked heir, and wife to
the Sea Snake Corlys Velaryon, Princess Rhaenys
Targaryen occupies a unique role in the royal
court of Westeros.
Rhaenys carries the less-than-proud nickname
of the Queen who Never Was — a reference
to her being passed up as successor to King
Jaehaerys I in favor of her cousin Viserys.
Being denied the Iron Throne does little to
curb Princess Rhaenys' influence and drive,
however, and she forms a fearsome couple with
her seafaring husband.
Rhaenys is played by TV stalwart Eve Best
in "House of the Dragon."
Best is probably most recognizable for her
longstanding role as Dr. Eleanor O'Hara in
"Nurse Jackie," and for her supporting performance
as Wallis Simpson in "The King's Speech."
More recently, she's appeared in the BBC miniseries
"The Honorable Woman," and Netflix's teen
fantasy show "Fate: The Winx Saga."
Initially an outsider in the court of King
Viserys Targaryen, Mysaria isn't even a native of Westeros.
And yet, she eventually rises to become what
HBO calls "the most trusted — and most unlikely
— ally of Prince Daemon Targaryen."
Mysaria is brought to life by Sonoya Mizuno,
an actor arguably known best for her many
collaborations with sci-fi auteur Alex Garland.
Mizuno has featured in several of Garland's
projects, including "Ex Machina" and the cosmic
horror masterpiece "Annihilation."
Her other film credits include "Crazy Rich
Asians," "Beauty and the Beast," and "La La Land."
Neither a Lord nor a ruler, Ser Criston Cole
might seem at first like the odd man out in
the main cast of "House of the Dragon."
Being common-born, he's not exactly overflowing
with riches or power, but he manages to defeat
Daemon Targaryen in combat in the premiere
episode, and make a strong impression on Princess Rhaenyra.
Just as Criston Cole is a bit of an unknown
quantity in "House of the Dragon," so too
is actor Fabien Frankel, the least established
star in the main cast.
A graduate of the Royal Academy of Dramatic
Art and the London Academy of Music and Dramatic
Art, Frankel got his big break in the BBC
One miniseries "The Serpent," which tells
the terrifying real-life story of a French
serial killer.
He also appeared in the 2019 romantic comedy
"Last Christmas," alongside "Game of Thrones"
star Emilia Clarke.
Where would a king of Westeros be without
his Kingsguard?
The white-cloaked guardians of the royal family
have always played a key role in "A Song of
Ice and Fire," and that tradition continues
in "House of the Dragon."
As Lord Commander of the Kingsguard during
the reign of King Viserys Targaryen, Ser Harrold
Westerling has a lot on his plate.
"House of the Dragon" sets him in a tumultuous
time for the family he's sworn to protect,
but he carries himself with dignity and professionalism
nonetheless.
Fans of the fantasy genre should be well acquainted
with Graham McTavish, the actor responsible
for embodying Ser Harrold in "House of the
Dragon."
He appears in all three of Peter Jackson's
"The Hobbit" films, as well as the Starz time-travel
fantasy epic "Outlander."
"It's fiction.
Outlander's fiction."
Just as comfortable in a voice booth, McTavish
has lent his vocal talents to a number of
video games and animated series and films,
including Dracula in Netflix's critically-acclaimed
"Castlevania" series.
That all barely even scratches the surface
of McTavish's career, which also includes
credits like the Saint of Killers in "Preacher,"
among many other smaller roles.
While the family may not be too important
during the events of "Game of Thrones," one
particular member of House Beesbury — Lord
Lyman — plays a key role in "House of the Dragon."
As an ally of the Hightowers and the Master
of Coin on King Viserys' Small Council, this
otherwise unassuming man holds a substantial
amount of influence in the realm at the start
of the show.
Who better to portray an unassuming bee lord
than experienced character actor Bill Paterson?
The Scot is best known in recent times for
playing Phoebe Waller-Bridge's father in "Fleabag."
Of every star on this list, Paterson may have
the longest resume, as his on-screen career
stretches all the way back to the early 1970s.
As such, he's been a mainstay of British TV
for decades, including a brief feature on
"Doctor Who" in 2010 alongside his "House
of the Dragon" co-star Matt Smith.